at least 22 soldiers are injured during
a military exercise that went way off
course at a major training site about
650 soldiers were taking part in a
nighttime parachute jump at Camp Shelby
in Mississippi the military says a plane
missed the drop zone sending
paratroopers crashing into the trees
some waited hours to be rescued and the
injured soldiers had been assigned to
the Alaska based 4th Brigade Combat Team
of the 25th Infantry Division David
Martin shows us what went wrong troops
began a nighttime Airborne training
exercise at Camp Shelby around 8:00 p.m.
Wednesday soldiers were parachuting from
c-130 transport planes when one of the
aircraft carrying 87 soldiers missed its
intended drop zone instead of landing on
the ground the troops crashed into trees
seven soldiers were taken to local
hospitals with non-life-threatening
injuries and 15 were treated by medics
at the scene firefighters were called in
to retrieve some soldiers whose
parachutes were tangled in the trees the
paratroopers were participating in
arctic anvil the rogers exercise Camp
Shelby has ever hosted about 3,000
troops from Alaska's 25th Infantry
Division are there for the month-long
training camp Shelby is the largest
state-owned military training base in
the country it covers more than 134
thousand acres from the height of the
Iraq war it was often the last stop for
National Guard troops training to go to
the Middle East most soldiers receive
light or moderate injuries training at
Camp Shelby is expected to continue for
CBS this morning David Martin